all right Vanessa Bryan posted an  emotional Instagram post in honor of her  13 year old daughter she shared this  photo guys yesterday from a touching  ceremony at Gianna's California school  that's where they held an event to honor  Gianna and retire her basketball jersey  in the caption vanessa writes my Gianna  god I miss you I've been so lucky to  have woken up to see your gorgeous face  an amazing smile for 13 years I can  barely read this guy's wish it would  have been until my last breath Gianna  and Kobe along with other parents and  two of Gianna's teammates were killed in  a helicopter crash in California on  January 2 that's all anybody's thinking  about really the Ness of the family's  know what this must be like for them  it's it really is unspeakable and so  painful I can't imagine him just the way  that she phrased it having to get up  every see a beautiful girl and we know  how much  Kobe loved his daughter and at what a  good player she was it's heartbreaking